[Applaus]
[Musik]
israels armee ist nicht die größe der
welt aber sie ist die effektivste denkt
mal darüber nach
wir sprechen hier von einem land mit
weniger als zehn millionen einwohnern
und dennoch hat es kriege gegen zehn mal
so große länder wollen zum beispiel
während des sechstagekriegs damals staat
israel mit einer bevölkerung von gerade
mal drei millionen einer
militärkoalition aus ägypten syrien und
jordanien
[Musik]
diese länder hatten damals zusammen über
40 millionen einwohner also mehr als 13
mal soviel wie israel das sie mit über
240.000 soldaten angriffen
das war die doppelte stärke der gesamten
israelischen armee mit anderen worten
aber hatten niemals mit einem sieg der
israelis gerichtet
aber die geschichte verliebt dann etwas
anders als erwartet
in nur sechs tagen löschen die
israelischen streitkräfte auch bekannt
als israel defense forces kurz etf ihre
feinde aus und ja ich weiß was du jetzt
denkst die israelis hatten eben
überlegenere waffen und technologie
nicht war nun das trifft auf heute zu
aber damals war das noch ganz anders
so waren beispielsweise 1973 während des
jom kippur tricks die waffen israels auf
demselben technologischen niveau wie die
ihres hauptgegner syrien
[Musik]
in der tat wollte die edf in den
fünfziger jahren ein paar moderne
kampfjets den berühmten air force qrf
des jura verfügten jedoch über die
modernsten flugabwehrraketen die es 200
diese wurden ihm von den sowjets
geliefert und wer hat auch diesen krieg
gewonnen genau israel ja jetzt denkst du
dir sicher kommen schon mag israel wird
militärisch von den usa unterstützt und
das ist eine wirklich mächtige hilfe ja
in diesem punkt hast du recht
israel ist das land das die größte
militärhilfe von uncle sam erhält aber
weißt du welches andere land auch eine
ganze menge der allerbesten waffen aus
amerika einkauft saudi arabien
die saudis verfügen damit über eine
ebenso große und moderne armee wie die
israelis aber wenn es dann zum
kriegsfall kommt sieht diese saudische
armee gar nicht mehr so gut aus in einem
anderen video hier bei visual politik
werben werde über das grandiose
scheitern der saudischen armee im kampf
gegen einen haufen von guerillakämpfern
erzählen dabei geht es um den konflikt
mit den mut ihre wellen aus dem jemen
der wohl auf eine jahrelange zermürbende
patt situation ohne endgültigen sieger
hinauslaufen wird mit anderen worten
weder besserer technologie noch die
unterstützung durch die weltmacht usa
sind das geheimnis hinter der
ausserordentlichen schlagkraft der
israelischen armee durch welche genauen
schlüsselfaktoren lassen sich aber die
großen militärischen erfolge der
israelis erklären heute stellen wir euch
jene fünf kernpunkte dar welche uns die
antwort darauf liefern werden schnelle
entscheidungsfindung
jede armee basiert auf hierarchie und
autorität richtig nun einige armeen sind
flexibler und einige weniger flexibel in
einem anderen video erklären wir euch
wie die saudische armee einen stärkeren
hang zur hierarchischen strukturen hat
und die einzelnen offiziere nur wenig
spielraum für ihre eigenen
entscheidungen haben das gleiche gilt
auch für andere arabischen länder wie
syrien oder ägypten
ein beispiel stellt euch eine
historische einheit vor die eine
position verteidigt angenommen ihr
hauptquartier wurde zerstört und die
soldaten an der front haben davon nichts
erfahren können
sind jedoch unter anderem schwerer
bestrafung darauf verpflichtet sich
genauestens nach vorschrift zu verhalten
und müssten daher nun warten bis ihnen
jemand aus dem nicht mehr existierenden
hauptquartier einen befehl erteilt sie
wissen während dieser zeit nicht ob sie
sich zurückziehen zurück schlagen oder
sich mit anderen militärischen einheiten
koordinieren sollen dann schön dämlich
war und jetzt wirst du dich vielleicht
fragen warum die arabischen armeen so
zentralistisch und unflexibel
organisiert sind wenn dies doch einen
offensichtlichen nachteil darstellt
vergiss nicht dass die meisten dieser
länder diktaturen oder absolutistische
monarchie sind wenn du ein tyrann bist
willst du dass deine armee unter deiner
totalen kontrolle stellt dadurch muss
jede noch so kleine entscheidung im
rahmen eines eng gesteckten micro
management von oben herab getroffen
werden um ja kein großes selbständigkeit
gefühl bei den offizieren aufkommen zu
lassen denn damit würde das risiko eines
staatsstreichs aus den reihen der armee
in die höhe schnellen
[Musik]
die israelische armee hast dieses
problem einfach nichts da ihre
angehörigen in einer freiheitlich
demokratischen gesellschaft leben und
diese fürchtet selbstständiges denken
nicht sondern sie fördert das kern wir
nun zum vorherigen beispiel zurück in
diesem fall müsste israelische
kommandant an der front nicht auf befehl
wagen er verfügt über eine gewisse
entscheidungsbefugnis die er nutzen kann
um augenblicklich zu reagieren und alle
sich zu bietenden chancen zu nutzen
[Musik]
tatsächlich ist dies in allen westlichen
armeen der regelfall die über garten und
lehne werden zwar zentralisiert gespielt
aber ihre ausführung ist dezentral
organisiert dies erlaubt eine wesentlich
flexiblere und reaktionsschnelle
organisation der streitkräfte aber im
gegensatz zu anderen westlichen ländern
verfügt israel noch über etwas
einzigartiges in seiner kultur die rede
ist von einer ziemlich unbekannten aber
ungemein wichtigen eigenschaft dieses
landes israel ist nämlich das am
wenigsten hierarchisch orientierte land
auf diesen planeten und das spürt man
dort überall in jeder hinsicht innerhalb
eines israelischen unternehmens zum
beispiel ist es normal dass ein normaler
angestellter jederzeit ein gespräch mit
seinem chef führen kann es wird ständig
debattiert und der autorität sender
menschen ist eher schwach ausgeprägt
[Musik]
in den siebziger jahren untersucht ein
niederländischer anthropologe namens
gert hof steht in verschiedenen ländern
das verhältnis der menschen
untereinander im bezug auf macht in
einem zeitraum von sechs jahren beträgt
der ibm mitarbeiter in bürmoos rund um
den erdball und erstellte daraus den
power distance index also ein maß dafür
wie weit die schere der macht zwischen
den einzelnen menschen auf geht vom
schwächsten bis zum mächtigsten mitglied
der organisation und unter all diesen
ländern hat er israel die allerkleinste
macht distanz während in den arabischen
ländern wie ägypten oder saudi arabien
die schere der macht am weitesten aus
[Musik]
mit anderen worten nirgendwo sonst auf
der welt werden die menschen stärker zu
einem durch flexibilität und
selbstständigkeit geprägten verhalten
erzogen als in israel innerer
zusammenhalt in israel ist der
militärdienst für jeden bürger
verpflichtet unabhängig von seiner
sozialen lage oder sein geschlecht ob
mann oder frau reich oder arm
alle müssen sich in der armee von ganz
unten hocharbeiten
[Musik]
die ganze wahrheit ist dies leider nicht
denn die ultraorthodoxen jüdischen
frauen und die arabische bevölkerung
bilden ausnahmen aber für den rest der
bürger besteht die wehrpflicht in diesen
stark leistungsorientierten israelischen
streitkräften das heißt jeder hat die
gleichen regeln zu befolgen um gefördert
zu werden hingegen einem allgemeinen
vorurteil ist ein solcher zustand in
anderen armeen nicht besonders häufig
anzutreffen während des zweiten
weltkriegs zum beispiel stiegen in der
britischen armee aristokraten
automatisch höhere ränge ein
als die bauern arbeiten solche
diskriminierend elitären zustände
schlagen sich auf die moral der truppe
nieder und erschwerend die bildung einer
armee welche sich durch kompetenz und
leistungsbereitschaft auszeichnet das
gleiche trifft auch auf die heutigen
arabischen armeen zu
so wird beispielsweise die saudische
armee ausschließlich von hohen beamten
und mitgliedern der königsfamilie
geführt
[Musik]
dabei gibt die hierarchie den ausschlag
der sohn eines saudischen prinzen wird
nie als einfacher soldat in müssen und
wie ihr euch sicher gut vorstellen könnt
zieht diese klassen mentalität so einige
nachteile mit sich die dann in einem
ganz bestimmten militärisch äußerst
entscheidenden knackpunkt kumulieren
[Musik]
kampfmoral im jahr 1973 trifft israel
gleichzeitig gegen die ägyptische und
die historische art wie wir euch bereits
am anfang erklärt haben war israel
damals noch nicht die technologische
kraftprotz wer ist heute ist syrer
hatten wie bereits erwähnt die
sowjetischen s200 und in den ersten
tagen zerstörten diese flugabwehrraketen
viele der israelischen anti israel
musste sich zurückziehen aber anders m
kam zu hilfe
das weiße haus schickte israel ein
ganzes bündel von waffensystemen mit den
sds 200 und die feindlichen radar
anlagen neutralisieren konnte es
handelte sich zum beispiel bosch körper
so genannte frist die die wärme
gesteuerten raketen in die irre führen
auf diese weise konnten die israelis
zurückschlagen und in kürzester zeit die
syrische luftverteidigung ausschalten
und rate mal was du als nächstes
passiert nun die arabischen soldaten
auch die am boden zitiert nun einfach
aus angst vor der israelischen luft
[Musik]
auf diesem bild könnt ihr sieben
syrische panzer sehen sie bewegen sich
nicht aber keiner von ihnen ist zerstört
was bedeutet das nun es bedeutet dass
die soldaten die sich in diesen panzern
befanden beschlossen haben das ist
besser wäre abzuhauen
denn je niedriger die kampfmoral desto
eher desertiert ein soldat und das ist
etwas was im arabischen armeen sehr sehr
häufig vorkommt
20 syrische einheiten der satiren in die
türkische provinz hatay
denkt mal darüber nach wenn du ein
israelischer oder amerikanischer
soldaten ist fühlst du eine gewisse
verbundenheit mit den politischen und
gesellschaftlichen system seines
heimatlandes und möchtest ihm treu sein
aber arabischer soldaten haben zu viele
verschiedene im konflikt miteinander
stehende ethnische nationale und
religiöse identität
[Musik]
stell dir vor du bist ein syrischer
soldat gleichzeitig aber auch kurt oder
mitglied der muslim-bruderschaft beide
gruppen werden von der syrischen
regierung bekämpft so wem also verspürst
du eine stärkere realität natürlich
bezahlt die armee deine miete aber wenn
ein leben in gefäßen du sowieso alles
verlieren würdest was ist ihr wichtiger
dein gehalt leben mit anderen worten
ganz gleich wie viel geld und welche
waffentechnologie eine regierung auf
bringt wenn ihre soldaten nicht stark
genug innerlich motiviert sind hat sie
bereits verloren und über diese tatsache
wissen die israelis besser bescheid als
jeder andere
[Musik]
um an kapital alle panzer haben motoren
auf der rückseite
warum normalerweise werden sie von vorne
beschossen und dann will ja dass so ein
kanzler auch noch einen treffer noch
fahren kann
aus diesem grunde sind die motoren so
gut wie aller panzer modelle vom
deutschen leopard bis hin zum russischen
team 90 eben auf der fahrzeug rückseite
angebracht allerdings die israelische
armee ira kürzer fahrzeuge nicht zu sehr
wie das leben ihrer soldaten aus diesem
grunde ist der israelische mag aber der
einzige kampfpanzer dessen
antriebsstrang sich an der vorderseite
befindet um als zusätzlicher schutz für
die besatzung zudem
auch ganz ohne ethische beweggründe kann
es sich israel nämlich nicht leisten
viele soldaten zu verlieren denn wie wir
bereits zu anfang erfahren haben ist
seine bevölkerungszahl im verhältnis zu
der seine feinde um ein vielfaches
kleiner
aus diesem grunde erhalten israelische
rekruten eine wesentlich intensivere
ausbildung als alle anderen mit scharfer
munition und top ausrüstung und vergesst
bitte nicht dass aus diesem land eines
der überlegenen nahtlos system überhaupt
kommt krav maga die lehre von
humankapital manifestiert sich auch beim
israelischen geheimnissen muss er als
einer der weltweit besten liegt
[Applaus]
wenn du eines tages zufällig nach israel
reisen solltest solltest du dir darüber
im klaren sein dass sie deine
telefonnummer und eine menge anderer
daten über die sammeln und auswerten
werden weil sie wissen dass
informationen mal macht bedeutet
[Applaus]
aber okay okay ich weiß was du jetzt
endlich sehen willst der grund warum du
dieses video angeklickt hast war sicher
dass du etwas über die aller modernsten
hightech waffen der israelis sondern
wollte ist nicht wahr
okay wir werden uns diesem deinem
innigsten aller wünsche nicht länger
widersetzen
[Applaus]
in israel irgendwann im laufe der 80er
jahre beschloss die israelische
regierung eine reihe entwickeln zu
lassen
eine wache von der sogar bis jetzt bis
vor kurzem noch niemand etwas gehört
hatte
man beauftragte also die staatseigene
rüstungsfirma raphael ein ganz
besonderes fahrzeug den sogenannten
perec zu ende
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dabei handelt es sich um einen
sogenannten waffenträger also ein
gepanzertes fahrzeug das nach außen
eigentlich wie ein ganz normaler panzer
wirkt aber in wirklichkeit ein panzer
jäger mit einem großen raketenwerfer ist
das heißt du dich ein wenig mit waffen
auskennst weißt du bestimmt dass dieser
unterschied im kampf ein himmelweiter
unterschied ist für den gegner
himmelweit im wortwörtlichen sinn panzer
verfügen gewöhnlich über eine waffenruhe
von zwei bis vier kilometern
die spikes raketen mit ihnen eine per
recht bestimmt ist können jedoch ziele
in einer entfernung von bis zu 30
kilometern erreichen nun stellt euch mal
folgende situation vor der feind werte
satelliten aufnahmen aus um das
bedrohungspotenzial der stationierten
israelischen waffensystemen abschätzen
zu können
jetzt sieht er dort viele normale panzer
und auf dieser grundlage erfolgt eine
ganze strategie planen aber dann
überraschungen diese panzer sind keine
panzer sondern etwas mit einer viel
größeren reichweite viele jahrzehnte
lang war die per recht einer der
geheimnisvollsten wachsen der
israelischen armee und die größter
vorteil war dass eben niemand etwas von
ihr wusste jetzt stellt sich die frage
warum das so war
warum kann israel eigene geheimwaffen
herstellen und andere länder nicht die
antwort darauf lautet dass es in israel
eine unglaublich große zahl an
technologieunternehmen gibt auf denen
eine ganze verteidigungsindustrie
aufbaut und diese ist absolute
weltklasse in einem anderen video werden
wir die davon erzählen wie ist israel
geschafft hat ein für ein so kleines
land
unvergleichlich erfolgreiches startup
ökosystem aufzubauen in den 80er jahren
schuf die israelische regierung nämlich
ein spezielles programm das so genannte
dieses programm bestand aus zehn
hedgefonds mit privaten und staatlichen
geldern diese mittel halten viele
technologieunternehmen zu gründen
und weißt du was die bevorzugte branche
so diese neue startups war natürlich die
rüstungsbranche schließlich handelt es
sich bei den ibf um einen reichen und
zuverlässigen kunden in unglaublich
kurzer zeit wurden dutzende von neuen
waffenherstellern gegründet unternehmen
die maßgeschneiderte produkte
herstellten um die anforderungen der
israelischen armee zu jedem moment
genauestens erfüllen
abwehrsystem iron dome bis hin zu dem
meer cover panzern und erbrecht die wir
bereits erwähnt haben
was ging währenddessen in den anderen
ländern vor sich
was passiert in saudi arabien wie ihr
wisst hat die saudische wirtschaft ein
problem sie ist sehr stark von der
ölförderung ab
natürlich sind die saudis dank des
erdöls reich geworden und können somit
die drittgrößte armee der welt bezahlen
die nur von china übertroffen wird und
natürlich von der der usa
[Musik]
aber teuer ist kein synonym für gut die
saudische armee kauft ihre panzer in den
usa und diese sind auf die bedürfnisse
der amerikanischen armee zugeschnitten
außerdem macht es dieser umstand viel
schwieriger eine geheimwaffe zu besitzen
weil er jeder weiß was man auf dem
internationalen markt kauft
[Musik]
und ja ich weiß was du jetzt denkst
nachdem dieses video gesehen hast wir
wollen die ganze zeit nur über die
wundersamen 100 waffen und die
unglaubliche überlegenheit der id r
sprechen oder nun nicht ganz denn die
israelische armee hat ihre
schwachstellen tatsächlich gibt es
organisationen wie er das leben verdammt
schwer machen könnten
nun lautet die frage an euch glaubt ihr
es gibt jemanden der die israelische
armee besiegen könnte was sind eure
meinung nach ihre schwachstellen bitte
schreibt uns eure antwort und meinungen
in den kommentarbereich jede woche laden
wir frische informative videos hoch also
bitte nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren
denn nur so verpasst du keines unserer
updates und wenn du der meinung bist das
dir dieses video etwas gebracht hat gib
uns bitte auch einen daumen hoch
machs gut und bis zum nächsten mal
shalom
[Musik]